[Music]
welcome
to the iron lords podcast
hello everyone my name is pete also
knows now though here for the ironlords
podcast
here to tell you all about siege
survival
gloria victus now this game is
a medieval type and style game where
you end up playing as this uh person
who has just been in the middle of um
their
castle in town has been uh sieged by
this
rival type of um no um i've actually a
group of people
now what ends up happening is what ends
up
the people and everything inside of this
castle
they end up destroying everything
and you still have troops out on those
front lines so what you're
looking to do is you're looking to
make sure that you can uh grow
and self-sustain yourself in in your
town
while this is happening you have to go
out and scavenge
every single night into the town to find
materials and things you need
now what makes this very interesting and
very
different than most uh of these types of
games are
well you have two different aspects you
have um the strategy
side of things which means you have to
make sure you build things in the right
order
you have the survival aspects because
the people that you
find that want to help and help you with
your town and grow things
they have their own like like you know
special needs and things like that
and you have to make sure you're
maintaining your resources properly so
that you
don't end up overdoing it and pretty
much destroying your whole entire
team in your town so over time you kind
of learn how to
deal with these things and it works out
very well
now every single night you're sent into
the town
to go scavenge for for goods and over
time you'll end up getting certain
supplies which will allow you to build
more specific objects within your town
now those
objects in your town like carpentry
board
or a farm or um
you know some type of like medical
like bandages or or things like that so
you have
multiple different things that cause you
to you know
figure that out but it is still
really really difficult to play i played
it for mo for for a handful of hours
and it made me feel like i was playing
um
that game wars mine where you're going
around and trying to
maintain survival and you're trying to
maintain things
without the combat and situations
and it was hard i felt it was harder
than that
now the interesting part about siege
survival
with it is that at the end of every
let's do you have your day phase which
is you building things and you taking
care of things in your in your town
you have your night phase which you're
gonna end up gonna go out and you're
gonna do your
um your your scavenging and you're
everything like that
if you don't get back to your to your
castle location
bo i should say or your your safe area
by the end of the night everyone can see
you and it turns into a real real
situation
with you trying to get back to your town
uh and you can
even like lose a character because the
guards from the other
rival castle will actually be there and
fight you and you'll have
lots and lots of problems so it's very
very hard for you to watch that
uh so to keep an eye on that when that's
happening
and then every couple of days what's
gonna end up happening is you're gonna
end up getting attacked uh but your
troops will attack their troops i'm
assuming because i've never had this
completed you will beat the game
when your troops kill off their troops
now
it's really really hard to maintain
your characters because you know you
have your characters
you have your i would say your four or
five characters
you start with one and overtime grows
and
you're trying to maintain them staying
served like alive
and you have to give your resources to
these troops it was very very
hard i lost characters because of hunger
thirst
um and and it was just
it was very very difficult um i really
would recommend this if you really love
those types of very hard uh survival
type games
uh even these the these city builder
type games i can
you can even call them i i thought it
was really enjoyable
very difficult to play i really think
that you guys
should take a look when you get a little
bit of time um
i thank you all very much for taking uh
you know a moment to listen to this
first
this first look video of
siege survival uh from us from the
ironworks podcast
i appreciate and thank you all make sure
you guys check out the iron lords
podcast on sunday
and myself i am sneldo i am on twitch uh
monday to friday
every morning and every night so please
go hit the follow buttons for us all
and thank you very much and have a
fantastic day
bye everybody
i look you can upgrade with a pot and
other materials
okay okay we can make a meal
get really close to him see how they uh
let's see how they're cooking
looks like his face is in the fire
that looks so dangerous
edward's face was in the fire
exactly where he left him shivering and
pressing
the eyes just
feed him
who knows but you managed you making me
bit by bit
dude let him rest
uh you recognize the discernment of the
town
i hear our own standards for her
we need arms
search the guard house look for weapons
and find out what happened to our men
not just matter
what do you want from me lady
yes for the hot sauce street and get
jerk
what are you kidding me
you are both getting food
and water
and you are getting
medicine
uh
nothing here what we can do
blind looks ill
thanks we know
um
[Music]
clearly when they are not nearly as
tired
they are pretty damn good
[Music]
um
slightly sick you need to take more meds
you need to get a makeshift bandage
[Music]
um
anything we can make here
could do that
i need to burn some corpses
[Music]
medicine
that's are you done yet there buddy
and then i want you to rest
i want i want that to happen because i
think you are going to need to go
out hopefully getting some food
i'm going to have you rest because i
think you need it
i'm very imp i'm actually way more
impressed with this game than i thought
it was going to be
um you're sleeping
uh you're gonna scavenge
what we're gonna do here is we're gonna
go to the craft district and see if we
can get some food
um
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
bring
chisel i don't know what we're gonna
need to get over here into this area
because i don't know if i even have to
go to cheap side to do it i don't think
i do though
all right let us pray we can do it
and take this way and we can hook hard
right what is this
[Music]
hmm
go to the rooftop
broken stuff
list the parts
and then behind a broken table
let's check the little scribe of this
talk to him
your close friends are you must stop
this right now or he'll bring
calm him down
let's help each other
then we split our oh that stinks
oh blocked
need a shovel for it go figure
damn it
i'm mad
two events here
it's water dirty water
without hop oh that veggies are around
the corner
but we have to the low town
i remember that's what was something
that would help us
that's all the food and vegetables
i want to do this
oh there's a lot more supplies over here
too
[Music]
i wonder what happens if we're outside
too long
before we get back because it might
actually happen
[Music]
all right get that right if the upgrade
this workbench
craft shovel that we need two tools
oh he did jacob did come that's nice
need fiber
so
um
he is really good at eating drinking
not good at fighting doing anything or
resting
all right so he's not the best of
characters to pick future
reference
um
i need fibers i mean there's not much i
can do
you continue to rest
drink something
bring something i thought you
go here
oh no
i mean i don't know what else to be
doing right now
and i can't really even upgrade or fix
anything i can't upgrade this yet
i need bricks planks and tools
the sore house needs materials and
planks
oh maybe i should do that because then i
can do those things too
all right hot planks materials
entry don't matter
still can't do anything about that huh
[Music]
the only way for us to look at the tools
and i think we're gonna need to upgrade
because once get that ernest
garden plot rat trap armory yeah i think
we're gonna have to
let's see about getting that done never
even thought of it
lions
fibers down too
[Music]
yeah oh
all right all right
so yeah bed bed
scavenge now why don't you
[Music]
scavenge and you sleep
or scout
scout because you're being a jerk too
you're a
dick all right so we're gonna need
[Music]
materials
uh food and armaments building materials
all right so cheap side and low side
we're gonna have to go down to the low
side
we're going to see about that we're
going to figure out how to get these
passages online too
get that going
we need building materials and fiber
building materials and fiber
it's dangerous
the blue material and dried meat will
take it
oh we can still make fodder out of it oh
the bad food that's water we don't need
water right now
you need a key where could it be
interesting it looks like a mausoleum
type too
also might be something we can use
possibly
materials we'll definitely be taking the
end fiber
i really would love to get back so that
we can start getting
those tools made up so we can start
making food plots
we start making food more often
people there
all right
uh
rob the man let him grieve
what the man grave rob
the man i was just running backwards
we're in safe zone now
all right i think we're gonna be
stopping stream readers for the rest of
the day
i think we're gonna
start closing up there's
okay so
what's your table
do that you
[Music]
go feed them
you need to eat
you need to
go back to work
you
[Music]
what other things do you have that we
can eat
um
you to make some planks
[Music]
you
[Music]
let's try some fibers
you will rest tomorrow
i think we're gonna have to make sure
jacob is in working condition
or
the next day i think we're gonna have to
have you
we need to be able to get some more food
once we get more food i feel like we're
going to be like
in the in the we're going to be in the
good
um
so
you eat and drink and then go in
you can sleep
you sleep
[Music]
you
any more planks no no
no good drink
[Music]
you can do that faster
blanks runes are not getting worse you
are fine
stop being baby
um
storehouse upgrade it's gonna be crazy
i'll tell you this we definitely need to
get
it's always in better working order
because we're gonna need to get these
shovels going
we're gonna need to get plots done and
things like that done
oh right is the night game
of hunger starving
you have to be the ones going to go
is he sleeping in the bed because
he's a rest tired
sleeping on the ground
all right
i want to see what happens if we get all
the way down to that that bottom one
again
we have that key
oh
oh no
that's pretty nice
oh we're all the way down there now the
temple of the forefather
not what i was expecting
[Music]
yeah you're hungry buddy
the campment
this is
another trader type person
they want food another person that wants
food like we don't
have food like what is wrong with you
people
now i'm sorry we don't have any food
all right
we'll do one more full cycle of days and
after that we'll get back to that
yes return did not bring any food back
which sucks
um
all right so
just take a quick second here
i think these guys
so
jesus fed
we need to
figure out how to get food
we need two
of these so we need wooden planks
all right victory
please like out cold
my god dying of thirst
hunger exhaustion
i wish i knew i would have gotten him
something to drink or
all right so what we're going to do is
we're going to try and go
to get food in the veggie area which is
straights out
right
actually is that
clean water dirty water
that is not clean water
we need like vegetables we need meats we
need things like that so
get as much as we can
i don't know how the hell
past that but it's really interesting
way to do it
come on give us more meats
ugh
one of these times i want to be like
you get like a cow it's like what huh
oh
this is one of those scenarios like i
wish i i wonder what's gonna happen
if we don't get back in time
oh no no
no
hey
that was not cool whatsoever
we're working on it
she died of hunger
oh boy
you get nothing
get water
this is like not gonna work
[Music]
[Music]
crafting
i wonder if we make more than one
three planks
nah don't need to repair three planks
you want from us people are greedy
and needy
all right
[Music]
[Music]
very sad
got very lucky on that last
scavenge
that was a really really far run
we don't have the ability to clean water
yet
i'm so pissed that that person can live
for one more day
it's all we needed was one more day
and we would have had food for them and
they would have survived
which sucks but unfortunately that is
the
downfall of doing what we're trying to
do here
oh
oh
the torches are definitely nice to burn
them
i was really hoping that you that stuff
for um
[ __ ]
run
oh my god i'm running the wrong way
hmm
crazy
so
[Music]
you